achieved with CryEngine
for the house tonight what chose to do
such getaway
take as many men as you need to ride
that find those names and breathe hey
ah
hi I'm the creative director of the game
you just saw I hope you liked it and I'm
here to tell you more about the game
about the people behind it and most
importantly about the reason why we are
here on Kickstarter
some time ago I realized that at the big
publisher I used to work there's very
little chance that I will be ever able
to make a game that I always wanted to
make so I decided to quit my well-paid
job and started a new company called
warhorse to develop an open-world
medieval realistic RPG you just saw
called Kingdom Come deliverance you can
think of it as a Braveheart game
majestic castles armored Knights
large-scale battles political intrigues
all set in large medieval open-world we
want to make the experiences Boulton
biggest possible real-world locations
real castles period-accurate costumes
and armor combat and fencing design with
the best swordsmen around and story
based on real historic events all this
on a foundation of solid game mechanics
of a true hardcore RPG like nonlinear
quest with multiple solutions branching
dialogues with points of no return
several roles to play lots of different
stats skills and perks and ultimate
character customization options we have
four layers of clothes and sixteen
equippable slots there is of course
crafting like blacksmithing alchemy and
even cooking and details like the need
to sleep and eat to stay healthy even
food goes bad if it's in your inventory
for too long deliverance is one large
open world you can grab your sword hop
on your horse and just the right to the
country or find people in peril to help
them solve complicated quest hunt wild
animals or take part in large battles
one of the things we are most proud of
is our combat system it's not easy to
make a good first person combat and we
believe we succeeded in that you can
move freely like in any other
first-person game but at the same time
you can attack various parts of
opponent's body with several different
attacks on top of that you can also
perform special moves and combos and
most importantly the whole thing is
based on inverse kinematics so every
store blow results in proper physical
correct reaction so to sum it all up we
are trying to mix the freedom and game
mechanics of Skyrim storytelling of the
feature setting of mountain blade and
the tough combat of Dark Souls into one
single package for people who like those
games TV series like Game of Thrones or
Vikings or movies like Braveheart
our team is based in Prague in the heart
of Europe where every town and village
is overshadowed by an old castle so we
have lot of places to draw inspiration
from
most of our team members previously
worked on other big open-world games
like mafia operation flashpoint and ARMA
series our lead programmer work on Forza
horizon our lead artist came from Crytek
where he work on Crysis 3 we are a new
team but we have worked with each other
in the past and most of us have 10 plus
years experience in the industry so I
believe that we are well qualified to
develop another open-world game
everything you saw so far was developed
by a team of just 25 people we are now
35 members and planned to double the
number so now you probably ask yourself
a question why we are here on
Kickstarter this is big expensive game
that will surely cost a lot of money
doesn't any big publisher want it the
answer might surprise you
warhorse is a relatively small studio so
far we have been funded by a private
investor and the cost of what you just
saw is about 1.5 million dollars things
look promising at first the producers we
met liked the game and the team but when
we've got to the sales and marketing
people problems came up at the time of
the pitching everybody thought that the
next-gen consoles are doomed and nothing
other than free to play MMOs for iPad
will sell so when we turn up with a
pretty unique new concept for consoles
it was flagged as very risky on top of
that we got a lot of questions like is
it going to be fun without Mexican
dragons and the negotiations were taking
forever
so finally nearly a year after we began
pitching deliverance to publishers we
came to a crossroads either we fold the
whole thing and do a free-to-play MMO
for iPad or we find some other way to
fund the game but deliverance is a big
and expensive game and we can hardly
hope to raise the whole budget on
Kickstarter alone so we made a deal with
our investor who has luckily been very
patient with us so far that since the
publishers are skeptical we would
approach you the gamers directly and if
we manage to raise relatively reasonable
sum of $500,000 it will prove to him
that the game is potential and he will
continue to finance us if we fail it
means that the publishers were right and
there is no demand for the game so it's
not going to happen and I think over
that amount will allow us to create
additional content and make it better
our game consists of three acts which we
want to publish separately the first one
has a 9 square kilometer map and 30
hours of gameplay the second act will be
released about eight months after the
first one it expanded map and similar
lengths between each act we plan to add
new features based on feedback from you
the supporters of our project our
backers will also get
access to the game in about six months
we will release a smaller level where
our backers can test core mechanics and
as development progresses we will add
new features like combat horse riding
and smoke quest when everything is ready
our backers will have early access to
the beta before release so if you liked
what you saw in the idea of large
medieval open-world RPG please support
us we believe there are many people who
like to play the game but it's simply
not possible with traditional publishers
so we cannot do it without your help you
will find more information about the
game under the video and will provide
even more in the future update thank you
for watching and thanks for your support
keep your money